this might get weird well your fried li
no I really were doing morning
announcements right that lunches pizza
also dared me to proud
hello welcome to our patreon this is a
thing we are now doing we are so excited
and obviously uncomfortably confused on
how to do this so bear with us Dean's is
shivering out of fear oh my god beans
okay he's very excited for this patreon
cuz she heard there are some part first
of all hi welcome if you're here that
means that you have some interest in
what we're doing so may Marie and I
started a podcast called this might get
weird a couple weeks ago this is exactly
where we record it's only an audio
podcast which is why this video might be
a little misleading it is a little
misleading but at the end of the day you
guys are gonna get a lot more content
consistently if you don't make a shower
yeah that's one of the main like
motivators behind doing this podcast is
that it is content we can create without
having to feel insecure physically Clee
and just really be ourselves truly
honestly be our gross trash dumpster
itselves
okay hey I'm speaking I'm or director
I'm projecting I'm projecting may mean I
used to do live show it's called this
make it weird y'all
[Music]
but then we developed it into a youtube
series called this make it
[Music]
and we did that for six months six or
seven months a hundred and fifty plus
episodes and it was a blast but it was
with a production company and when that
kind of went away grace and I thought
well instead of that kind of it
definitely went away they cut our
funding and canceled the show
for sure we thought let's actually do
something that's only dependent on us
that isn't with like a larger entity
just the two of us which as you can see
means a little more bare-bones in
production but not any less and
entertainment value if anything it
allows us an opportunity on this podcast
to talk about things that we've never
talked about in videos to share stories
that we've never shared I've never
talked about already the things that
we've talked about in the two episodes
that we have three now grazin I've been
doing YouTube for a long time but people
who have been watching us for a while
first of all thank you
second of all you've grown up - yeah we
don't want to just talk about things
that seem appropriate to a YouTube's
algorithm or to that demographic we just
want to talk let me would normally
[ __ ] talk you know sitting at my
kitchen counter or back here right there
at the end of the day when we say we
want to come on here and like tell what
we've been up to
unfiltered unedited adjust air our dirty
laundry we're literally recording this
beside my dirty laundry yeah there's so
many layers of dirt and filth but you
will get width of this make it weird
podcast we're getting to figure out this
system as it goes so it's a little rough
around the edges but we're super [ __ ]
pumped one like we said we want to be
raw and real with you guys and then with
that we want to create a community of
you guys being able to talk to each
other talk to us and it feel like I
don't know a safe space that's one of
the things I love so much when I first
started doing YouTube and like with camp
Takota and things like that it felt like
everyone was building it together it
wasn't even like here's a peek behind
the curtain it was like there's no car
and like come on in and I feel like a
little bit of that has been lost so we
want to bring that magic back and like
have this cool special place for you
guys to come let's tell them what they
can get you're on patreon I feel like
that oh I
the basic intro tier is $5 and it's our
classic dollars that's a goddamn steal
yeah I'm auditioning for an infomercial
ad that gets you we should look at I
don't want it too cleared up this is
gonna get you lots of bonus things this
could be like footage that we throw up
that accompanies a story we talked about
on the podcast what's on our camera roll
it's like you found our phone that we
left behind at a bar and you get to go
through it and you knew that the
password is 6969 you're also gonna get a
chance to get into the this might get
weird discord chatroom something we're
learning how it works we can talk to you
guys whenever we want we can also
schedule like actual chat conversations
it reminds me very much of like a once
two messengers I know I feel very
nostalgic about it and excited very
ballet double-oh-seven vibes which was
my first screen name because I wanted to
show them I love for the art of dance
and ballet but I didn't want to come off
too girly so I added a double-oh-seven
and the other thing it's gonna get you
is access into our merch store
eventually we'd like to create some cool
stuff and maybe not just even just
clothes like lots of weird fun thing it
unlocks our merch store down the road
you guys can post on the community side
of patreon to like things that you want
as merged so we can develop this
together so that's the five-dollar
weirdos so with all patreon pages as we
go further down the different tiers you
get everything else that's been
mentioned above you $15 tier it's called
the crate you see where we're going with
this they get early access for when we
announce tours this is from Grace and I
doing live stuff and we'd like to do it
again maybe the podcast live so you guys
get first access to tickets be it
regular tickets or VIP or what have you
you're gonna be the first ones to know
about absolutely you guys also once we
launch merch we'll get a discount on the
merch BAM the really exciting thing for
the $15 tier I think is that y'all are
gonna get a bonus podcast every night
we are barely able to deliver once a
week let alone a bonus episode so that's
a true privilege that's right 30 minutes
of extra content every month coming at
you at some point these are gonna be
more of like QA type of podcast this
will be more engaging with you guys yeah
Pacifica Lee the next year do our
beautiful doof's at $30 will get access
to the brain trust discord this is a
separate chat and we're exclusive chat
in which we are gonna derive a lot of
ideas for what we want to talk about on
podcast week to week and explicitly
answer those questions in our bonus
podcast episode every month that's a
very intimate chat that's a smaller chat
room that we're gonna go into more often
to kind of engage with you guys to get
the questions you want to hear answer
and also just to get suggestions of what
else you'd like to see be it hear it on
the podcast or for our extra content
because the doof's also get an exclusive
download every month this is more in the
video form we are promising we have some
ideas of original content that we want
to create in video form we I'm gonna say
we under step our aunts France but they
review our podcasts or they take over
going inside the brains of beans and
goose and what that combo would sound
like we just want to do something weird
that we wouldn't put on YouTube that
we're gonna make specifically for you
guys next up oh baby try and guess I
mean you guys could see this coming
guess how much I mean oh sorry that's a
pun to it coming Oh gross oh I liked it
I'm disgusting guess how much this cheer
is $69 baby just like grace helbig's
phone passport delete your nudes this we
understand is kind of an insane tears
$69 a month's supporting us anyone who
would do that
good thank you this is a joke for us but
honestly if you do subscribe to this
tier we're gonna lose our goddamn we
have actual tears we're only allowing 69
people to be in the 69 tier because
you're the first tier that gets
something you get a twice yearly
mr. loss of items picked by us we are
not going to give you any clues as to
what's gonna be in this mystery box and
you guys 69 of you if it reaches max
capacity are gonna be the only ones to
get it I just want at least one person
to sign on to this tier because I want
to create these boxes so bad
treat yourself join the 69 pervs it'll
be so much fun also explaining to your
parents why you need to use their credit
card to sign up for this tier would be
an amazing video Jason Hornet throw it
on discord in addition to the mystery
box and all the other things we're gonna
do a livestream with you every month so
only 69 of you will be hanging out with
us in a livestream that we're kind of
calling the pregame you know grace and I
hung out last night we have a drink
beforehand
yeah instead of just sitting on our
couch we're gonna sit there and have a
martini and pregame putting on our
makeup having a drink before we go do
something fun our pervs will be right
there along watching us and interacting
with us that couldn't be a more true
Internet sentence I know and then
finally for $500 a month you can be a
[ __ ] fool okay we looked at other
patriotic all had these insanely large
expensive tiers
like crazy tier that we were like who
would pay that much a fool so we decided
we should make our own as well and then
we realized that the people that might
actually sign up for this tier might
need some guidance in their life so the
thing that they're getting in addition
to everything that you're getting from
every other tier is a two-on-one life
coaching session with mamrie and I
because we are obviously experts on how
to live our life correctly listen to any
of the podcast episodes
mhm every three months we will Google
chat or whatever the easiest way to do
it is we're still figuring it out it's
gonna be the two of us and you and we'll
just hang out and talk and give you
advice or you can ask us anything and we
will either answer you or politely avoid
answering intimate questions right it'll
be a little live KO session because
clearly you don't know how to spend your
money yeah but we appreciate it and we
would love it but a lot but would love
for you to join this tier we're gonna
try to
put a lot of effort into all of this
even if you're just coming on to the
weirdos tier like we want to have a lot
of content up there we are really
excited about this and we're really
thankful in advance that you guys want
to be a part of this journey and that
you're enjoying the podcast so far get
on this train wreck of a train right now
you really got I'm okay with it
I think I'm just self-aware thank you
guys if you have already subscribed to
this patreon it says it subscribe um I I
don't know I thought it was I thought
you were saying patron for a month like
I'd like come along for the journey it
should be a great time if anything
you're gonna feel better about yourself
by watching how poorly we are able to
handle and figure out things why not if
you guys get in the discord you can like
suggest to sign off cuz it's weird every
time this make it weird